hi guys I'm Greg I'm John we're gonna
give you an episode today of our segment
that we want to make a weekly thing
hopefully it catches on with y'all we
love the audience participation point
and smile shanghaied on how it could
work is this side don't well we have a
list of so many movies that haven't
talked about to have sequels crossovers
reboots remakes or movies that we just
didn't know think we're very good and
how we think they could have been better
but today we're going to start off with
a shanghaied Don start a little small
here it was announced not long ago a
couple months ago at the director of
Napoleon Dynamite not gonna be directing
ya shanghaied on he's gonna be Jared
Hess yeah he's gonna be directing chanc
know jon heder he's gonna be directing
shanghaied on there's no plot revealed
so we came up with our own quad with the
plum he came up right on his own concept
for shanghaied dawn let's pitch it to
you I'll see if ya like it our not
here's how we think it could work yeah
it's been many years since the last
shanghai knights was was it yeah so we
want to pick this up fifteen years after
the events are shanghai nights so we
have our characters jackie chan and no
Wilson Chon Wang and Roy O'Bannon they
now live in hollywood california
specifically chinatown in the 1910s so
with this concept we have that Roy he's
a struggling writer he's trying to
produce his stories kind of piggybacking
off of where we found him in the second
movie like peddling these serials about
his great adventures but now he's trying
to get a film made about his life and
you know the crazy because in the end of
shanghai nights he was talking about you
know you should get in a moving picture
yeah like that those things so now check
we're leading into that to the unmoving
pitchers haven't quite been a thing at
this specific time yet specifically in
Hollywood they haven't hit the landmark
monumental moment you know they're
experimenting it's it's time to jump on
the train exactly exactly so he wants to
produce stories that he's writing he
wants a ride and direct he has all these
great visions he really believes in the
impact of cinema meanwhile Sean he's
running a dojo Yama kung Fu's dojo
Chinatown with Lynn he lives with his
sister Lynn his hot ass sister Lynn who
i'm assuming after 15 years is still
really hot we have it in our plot that
linen Roy they didn't work out they
didn't stay together because you know
Roy is he's Roy Roy he can't always be
committed you just can't stake he's he's
a hopeless romantic but he probably gets
bored falls in love with some other
chick he's just playboy still you know I
like the idea of Roy still beginning
like oh oh play boy oh boy but not just
writing Lynn directly out of the movie
like yeah exactly and our story linen
Shawn they run the dojo together and
they live directly across the street
from Roy Roy's the only white guy
currently living in Chinatown so with
this plot that we have with sean and roi
right now they miss each other but you
know he can't be friends we have ideas
for scenes were like I probably secretly
meet up or talk with a it's ackward that
they live across me know cuz Roy can't
afford to leave me please I can't afford
to live right up street from his ex and
his best friend we can't really hang out
yeah ceptin seizure so we're gonna have
like those like bromance moments or like
they bump into each other how are you
I'm good I'm sorry you all right how's
the school that's good how the stories
sage McCallister pick it up exactly to
kick off the plot though Roy has this
brilliant concept yeah really an idea he
wants to do a movie based on the
adventures that Shawn and Roy went on
primarily the events that took place in
shape i'm aaron and shanghai nights he's
thinking this would be a great idea if
they did a movie based off those things
so what happens is there's an
up-and-coming producer who's like
interested in film he has a lot of
money's a financier he meets with Roy
but he rejects the idea he's look
because he really believes that you know
like no one's gonna watch a movie about
starting a Chinese guy at all yeah it
sounds ridiculous why would anyone watch
that unless it's like one of those like
oddity newsreels or something yeah
exactly we're not gonna produce a motion
picture you know we're not right cuz you
know there were a lot of racial tensions
in
in the early 10th century and whatnot so
we figured we would kind of crammed that
indoor store exactly so this is that's
this is still the setup rat right yeah
yeah meanwhile with Sean story there's
another dojo in Chinatown who we don't
have a character named yet we wanted it
to be played by Sam sammo hung if you
guys don't know was one of the people
that you know Jackie Chan worked with a
lot back in Hong Kong Sam Long's and a
few things out here in America cuz you
know last one had donnie yen so let's
get sama hung in there and I feel like
routine IT these two in an American fell
together to be pretty [ __ ] sweet cool
yeah and he has his own studio and what
happens in this in our little plot Sean
students Jackie Chan students and sammo
hung students have like a feud going on
where they break out into a fight and
this is all in Chinatown that's
happening for some reason they break out
into a fight around the same time Roy is
taking a meeting with a producer and the
producer finally sees like oh [ __ ] this
martial arts stuff is crazy this can
cobble way cool on film we can
capitalize on them yes exactly but that
spells out trouble just as much as it
spells out a way for them to get this
movie made so Roy what he does he meets
with Sean about putting this movie ate
together Sean agrees to help out with it
because you know Roy's like what I
really want to do is capture the action
see ya always want to get the martial
arts in there it's a chance for them to
get back together and to tell their
story and to rekindle their friendship
also it can help you know the school it
can help the yeah the community like cuz
wen Zhong wants to do is like you know
like that yet promote martial arts and
then it could get people interested in
learning about martial arts and it can
also and Chong could use a lot of the
money to help out the you know yeah he
wants war more in China and China or
trying to yeah you know he wants to make
the community better you know for four
people setting up a life in America you
know exactly so they so here we have our
plot they're putting together a movie
that's inspired by their lives and then
you know the casting process begins and
here's where I think we could have a lot
of fun I thought I'd be cool you know
like this is early Hollywood shanghai
knights played with the fact that you
know young aaron taylor-johnson was
young Charlie Chaplin I thought it'd be
cool if you brought him over here bring
him to bring back Aaron taylor-johnson
to play and even older like Charlie
Chaplin again but just get Robert Downey
jr.
yeah are you really cool and um hey
Quicksilver Iron Man Bowl play Charlie
movies crossover chaplains and you know
you could have other moments where you
include others silent film stars like
Buster Keaton Harold Lloyd cuz part of
the fun of both of the movies is like
when especially the second movie is like
when they bring in like other [ __ ] from
history or you know from ya like that
fight scene that was in the marketplace
I was like a tribute to singing in the
ring yeah yeah what attributing older
movies and stuff like that silent era
movies and early Hollywood movies but
also the second movie has all that stuff
with Arthur Conan Doyle and Sherlock
Holmes yeah stumbling across things that
we know now but like that's really toys
with a historical fiction yeah they
bumbling they bumble their way through
little little nuggets and if you look at
like Jackie Chan's career especially in
Hong Kong cinema like he had a film
called Project Dane he's done other
movies to where he does actions he does
action scenes and stunts that are very
specifically tributed to silent films
and he's a well-known like a huge fan of
like Buster Keaton yeah I in Charlie
Chaplin too especially so this would
really hone in on the Shanghai noon in
Shanghai Knights were a lot of love for
what Jackie Chan actually love ya in
cinema as well so I feel like it'd be
cool it really capitalize on all this
stuff and this would be I mean just like
you know as nerding out over the
logistics of making the movie like I'm
sure Jackie Chan will be thrilled to
actually I make one of these movies in
the silent era and like really ya dig
right and yes you know exactly exactly
so I feel like a lot of the fun ways the
movie could play out sort of is we could
see the fun process of the film being
made a lot of the fun moments of them
recreating moma Shanghai noon in
shanghai nights we thought be funny if
like they you know like if Roy was
writing and directing the film but he's
but they're not starring in the film
about them like they can't have a young
a different stage McAllister production
yeah exactly you could have like yuppers
plane a young Roy O'Bannon I don't know
who could play young Wilson I can't off
the top of my head think of a david
henrie wizards away really know you know
who i just saw on an episode of black
mirror who might be able to do it
actually is that do you remember 22 Jump
Street yeah remember the blond guy yeah
that guy that would be cool who could
probably play young Roy O'Bannon
and so that unique an editor a montage
moments where they're putting the film
together they're filming it you see that
Roy and Sean they get to be friends
again you know that's something that
they've missed out on as they haven't
been friends for a long time they have a
goal together and they're there wreaking
their revisiting the revisiting the
memories of them made them so close you
know and that's also just like if you
were gonna bring this franchise back I
mean you know that's good on ya warm the
hearts of anybody who loved above all
yeah it's probably one of the better
ways to to do that thing where you're
like remember this from the past movies
this would be a more fun and more like
justifiable way I think of actually
doing that too yeah and that opens up a
cool thing I think for this because the
fun and game starts to become watching
them recreate the moments and then
slowly watching the movement watching
how they recreate them change over to ya
as one of the conflicts of this movie's
gonna be that as they continue filming
the movie keeps getting changed by this
producer yeah less and less like real
life and basically making Roy look like
he's [ __ ] to me yeah i'm making Sean
look like his bumbling you know yeah ok
like one thing we thought would be fun
you know cuz there's a whole big con
just there's still a really big upset
when especially the Asian community
looks back on it would like Mickey
Rooney & Breakfast at Tiffany's yeah you
know like so a sting like a white I like
the idea of them having a scene where
they cast a white guy to play John John
yeah but like they have a fight but like
Roy and Sean are butting heads about it
but it's what the producer wants and he
always like no we good we can make it
work clanking others he's always got
away we can make yeah exactly and you
know we thought like every funny of Roy
invented the director cameo yeah yeah
and yeah just like a dress a bunch of
little things throughout film history
like maybe they have to do reshoots they
reshoot like all of Sean scenes with a
white actor so that you know just like
start poking you can poke fun at movies
too while you're doing and what we're
keeping that fun it would be neat if you
like the student start to question the
integrity like Sean would get his
students involved as like stuck men on
this film you know to play a lot of the
fight scenes and whatnot and making jabs
man he's bringing work to the committee
know like this is upsetting them I don't
want this to be just a joke like like
racist stereotype jokes I want like when
the racist stereotype stuff comes in for
it to be like affecting the Asian care
in this movie to be like this is [ __ ]
up kind of reflecting on modern times
today so around like the middle of the
film I imagine like a cool fight scene
that would happen where they're filming
a scene they're almost like they're
filming like one of their big moments
but then like a bunch of masked figures
attack the set and they all know martial
arts too and I thought it'd be a cool
fight scene we're like Jackie Chan gets
into a fight with a bunch of these max
mast warriors where he has to use like a
lot of film prop sets because when cool
things about Jackie Chan fights is when
he uses props so instead of just using
like real-life props he's using like
movie set props and everything well
that's part of the fun about of any
movie about making a movie is you get
those scenes where you get to kind of
like a bargain to see even out of a set
you know and see what's going on behind
and sort of use all the things that the
dispose of like there's so much ya do
with that for a Jackie Chan style fight
that would be pretty magical yeah
exactly that'll be like the middle point
of the film were you know like enemies
start coming in conflict starts really
coming in we learned that this was sammo
hung students that attacked the film
said that were trying to like prevent
this film from being made they feel this
film is an insult to Chinese people this
is a little bit after the gold rush
where a lot of Chinese immigrants are
really being exploited and they feel the
Americans are exploiting their culture
even more yeah it's it's a tough time in
American history yeah lots of ethnic
communities and I also you know maybe
like maybe he's got some of sammo hung
students like working as some people on
the movie and he's really not about that
you know yeah there are lots of
potentials for conflict between yeah so
we imagine like as a film progressively
gets made Roy and Sean have to keep
conforming to this like producers ideas
which keeps making the film more
insulting and more racist stereotypes
and like hun and and Roy that drives
them apart them yeah because Roy's
pretty tone-deaf yawns trying cuz you
know there is a greater good involved
but at what cost instead of just
recreating moments from Shanghai noon
and shanghai nights they recreated so
much to the point where did the Chinese
people just look like they're all bad
guys yeah and the only good Chinese
character is kind of an idiot and he's
also not even Chinese yeah it's not even
Chinese and all the white people are the
heroes in the film you know it's just
really making Chinese people look bad
then also learn a little bit of history
about the producer I know we're a little
over the place for here but you know
just a concept yeah this is a real set
piece you know and we learned that the
producer made a lot of money off of you
know the gold rush primarily using
Chinese immigrants to do his labor he
doesn't really give a [ __ ] about Chinese
people Sean departs film he's just
exploiting the culture yeah and Roy's
having a hard time making the movie
questions the integrity of his own soul
and you know it's like we have ideas for
where this can go with a finale and
stuff but the basic plot point of this
in the fun of it would be putting Roy
and Sean in the silent film era which I
think they would just love doing yeah is
being part of like old-school Hollywood
especially since like there's elements
of Shanghai noon and shanghai nights
that specifically played to the silent
film era so why not you go there would
do that you know each one you know it
takes some stuff from its time in place
and adds it to the character of the
movie yeah and each one you know we
rejoin them at a different point in life
and so I feel like this is a cool time
because they're both a little bit older
now like it's a cool time to embrace
that make a story that's both fun and
referential but also new and relevant
and relevant today because there's so
much talk about you know Asian actors
not getting the treatment they deserve
in Hollywood yeah and so this would rip
off that'll perfect opportunity yeah
yeah so I think this would be a really
fun movie a really fun opportunity not
exactly sure how the finale would go
down we came up with like a bunch of
ridiculous ideas is always gonna learn a
lesson for ya Roy realizes he was kind
of selling out again for more money and
this is in an insult to Chinese people
we kind of thought like it would be cool
to have like a showdown maybe at the
mann's chinese theater which I know
historically wasn't Billy but have some
like show downtown mirror whoever
thought you might be neat if you somehow
brought back Donnie yen's character you
know yeah to seize all famous now yeah
and I don't know maybe maybe Roy tries
to destroy them yeah maybe Roy realizes
I what I thought would be in a great
ender to this too is like maybe Roy and
Shawn once everything is sorted out you
do like a 22 Jump Street ending where
you just see a bunch of little bit
different like Shawn and Roy have their
own movie series now where they just
take on different man I was like and it
is those books like I like that motif in
the second movie so like you could end
this with just a bunch of previews for
like John and Roy take on the yeah
Jonathan Roy meet the Wolfman yeah I
don't like they're just Abaddon cut it
out of a self oh yeah so this is our
basic in general concept you know we
just wanted to share that with you guys
would you guys think of it what would
you guys add to this or what would be
your idea I don't think you have a
script yet Hollywood you think this can
be a pretty cool ideas I think this
would be fun I feel like there's a lot
of fun territory to explore here I mean
first Shanghai noon is rarity East meets
you know westerns yeah and then the
second one is like London territory
under violent old fish out of water yeah
and this one I feel is just the cisco
straight for what they've been kind of
paying homage to from the beginning yeah
yeah directly any other older they're
settling down man they're making a life
times of change yeah I mean there's no
real romance and here of course you got
to have that in there yeah well I think
they should make Sean android gay I'm
sure I can do it I would be really happy
about that yeah that'd be really cool
it's like an did it they fell in love
with you Thunder picking up I would love
that would be that would be so touching
although even though even then i'm
thinking like you could probably have a
pretty funny montage where Roy is trying
to use the auditioning process is his
own dating service and John's like dude
this is messed up yeah yeah like he's
just always trying to chat up the
actress or something like that all right
guys we can subscribe today please do it
we would love to have you as a
subscriber John's reasons to Jerry on
Twitter and Instagram and you can follow
the social media sites that he is the
social media manager of facebook.com
slash blue mouse and the real rejects
take care hopefully Jackie Chan watches
us and says she'd uncle Jackie Chan
adventures